DEFENSIVE ZONE BUT AUSTIN CROUSE
MAKES THE PLAY THERE. STARTING
THIS ONE, NO QUESTION ABOUT COYU
TOUCHED ON.
46 SAVEST GENERATES
A REBOUND AND WHO IS THERE, LAD.
>> THE THEY NEED TO SCORE GOALS
AND IN ORDER TO DO THAT AND MORE
PUCKS AND MORE PEOPLE I SAN JOS.
BEHIND THE NET FOR  FIND.
THAT QUIET A
OUT.
TRYING TO SPREE CONOR GOES ACRO
TO THE
AND JETS WIN A DRAW.NDS TO GO.
THAT'S GOING TO DO IT
LAST 45 TO A MINUTE AND STARTED
BECAUSE OF FACEOFF WIN THERE WIN
CROUSE AND PHIL KESSEL AND GLOVE
SAVE BY  BACK HANDS ONE
LONG, LONG
BENCH.
PICKS THAT PASS OFF AND IS
DANCES STYLE OF PLAY AS
THEY PLAY BACK TO CENTER.
FISH OUT OF WATER AS A FORWARD.
>> SR THE C THE SICK
REAL GOOD MOVE: UP THE CORNER
SCHEIFELE GOES DOWN FRONT.
COPP IS THERE AND HEE MARKER AG
AND ALSO AGAINST THE COVER UP
AND CAN THAT'S TWO MORE RIGHT
THERE.
THAT'S AN AREA YOU HAVE T
PUCK HAS GOT THEY NEED IT ALL.
IT ENDS
HELLEBUYCK AND THERE'S A REBOUND
LAYING THERE RIGHT IN FRONT AND
SHOOTS AND SENDS IT THE LINE EV
COULD HAVE WANTED KEEPING THE